It's
not over yet, is it?  Only the real thing can stand in that ring.Take
me.Is this really what you
want?
Wait.
I know that there is a lot of information flying around,
but what is the truth about weapons and certain things? Just as
Shiro said earlier, those who stand in the ring of Megalonia must be real people who can convince everyone
.
It's not a boxer who won byes
, it's [music] Oh,
Hokuriku tea, I
didn't trust you
Tama-Nether
I finally understand why I was chosen as the successor I'm the one who sets the
rules This is my
last
chance  Brother,
ah ah ah
I feel like I was able to speak with you honestly for the first time
From now on I'll crush you with all my strength without hesitation The
sound of Lunia Final 1 will be played Here we will decide the 3 matches of Shirotomikyu Daigia inferiority
[music]
nan
me
[applause]
[music]